what's going on there reject nation greg
here today i will not be meeting up with
john and coy until midnight tonight for
moon night episode five but uh there's
this new doctor strange tv spot that's
out normally if you guys follow this
channel we usually wait for a few to
come out then we kind of cover them at
the end of the week but i've been blown
up on social media about this one
particular spot so it must be something
special i saw it dropped at like
midnight last night which is an unusual
time for them to drop a tv spot for dr
strange but either way i want to see
what all the hype's about if you guys
can leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated let's see what is going on
today
[Music]
strange it's time in ten days
something to prepare you
for the truth
everything you've ever known whoa look
at this
stephen
moment
the illuminati will see oh
[ __ ]
no way
did they really just confirm that
strange radio pg-13 see it in premium
large format
ah you sons of babies i get why you were
all telling me to do that that just woke
me up
oh that's crazy that is wild
they really just confirmed the
illuminati in this tv spot i mean
we all knew we all knew they were more
than likely to be in here i just wasn't
expecting marvel to actually confirm it
themselves so that's pretty exciting
hell yeah there's a lot of cool new
visuals in here you know it's pretty
crazy to be watching this movie in just
a few days and not have any idea how any
of this is really gonna go down i have
not been keeping up to date with leaks
or anything of that nature watching this
footage and just all the things that
just keep popping into mine i'm so
excited to have so many things just be
finally freaking answered
stephen strange the illuminati will see
you now i mean right down to this moment
with the illuminati having that be
revealed by mordo the way that they edit
the trailer together here though at one
point you see someone walking and i
remember this was pointed out before
that looks like that might be blade up
there as part of the illuminati i think
they try to trick you with the trailer
editing because you have mordo saying
his line overlapping when he's looking
at strange with the ultron bots behind
him it looks like it's definitely mordo
walking to the illuminati seat so is
this version of mordo the same mordo
that we saw in the previous doctor
strange movie or is this a variant of
mordo who is part of the illuminati i
have no idea either way i'm excited to
find out and there's some empty seats in
there that i'm sure they cgi'd out some
folks who were gonna get officially
unveiled when the actual movie comes out
i'm just so excited to find out i think
it's neat how the trailers have kept it
really focused and exciting for our main
players you know doctor strange america
chavez wanda especially this brought it
back to guys don't forget there's going
to be some amazing cameos up in this
[ __ ] and just like the little bits of
details that they added here you know
even with doctor strange being escorted
to the illuminati to give the ultron
butts a little bit more personality that
way when you know wanda does go banana
sandwich and murders a few of them like
at one point the ultron bot pushes
steven strange it feels like one of
those ruthless guards who are escorting
like a prisoner and just pushing them
like get moving get going that way you
learn to not like them so when they die
you don't feel bad nothing can prepare
you for the truth everything you've ever
known led you to this moment you know
the other thing i got to point out too a
lot of the time when
marvel movies come out or even the shows
there tends to be some type of event or
something that happens that causes many
you know the easter egg people and the
theorists to go this thing could change
the mcu forever this could have serious
ripple effects and consequences moving
forward and nine times out of ten it
really doesn't sometimes it does
undoubtably but nine times out of ten it
doesn't i really feel like this movie
especially is going to change marvel
cinematic universe or at least like the
direction of the the following phase
this will be one of those movies that
after it comes out it's not going to die
down after a week or two there's going
to be theories unfolding for such a long
time because they are teasing us with
that like nothing can prepare us for the
truth the fact that they keep cutting
around to pretty much like the same
scenes when you know damn well that
there's going to be a lot of traversing
the multiverse a lot of dimension
hopping i really feel like we've only
gotten like a teaspoon of madness
just in these clips alone it's time
like i love the shots early on with
america chavez of where she's uh you
know in the star portal when dr strange
goes in there and tackles after her and
they're escaping through it and the star
portal stuff looks great the texture
looks awesome there's a lot of great
visual depth to it like when you think
of star portal it sounds like maybe this
would be a little cheesy in context but
when you have like a visual effects team
like this backed with
sam raimi's direction it just looks
exquisite
and then there's like this other shot
here where it seems like america chavez
is running away with defender strange
from watching all the tv spots and
trailers i'm concluding that this is
probably the opening scene of the movie
this is the prologue or part of the
setup i really don't know i haven't like
i said haven't been keeping up to date
with the actual plot leaks for this film
it seems to me that defender strange
will probably die early on in this movie
and it'll involve him having to save
america chavez and america chavez is
trying to get to doctor strange but i
feel like that opening scene is just
going to set the ground i kind of like
how uh i don't know what a good
comparison would be i don't know when i
went to like man of steel on krypton but
i don't feel like that's the actual same
comparison but you know what i mean
really set in the ground floor for the
stakes and a great visual feast right up
front any additional shot with wanda i
just really eat up this moment here with
wanda where she's surrounded by chaos
magic as she's doing a ritual and then
of course the clutch so much zooming in
on the eyes it's such a classic sam
raimi thing to do but i can't quite tell
what it's zooming into it sort of seems
reflective of the i think they're
zombies and what if we explored like
zombie strange and so it seems like
that's the teddites of the mcu right
here and it seems like that's what
they're going into i don't know and i'm
excited that i have no idea what's
really going on there could be some type
of dark dimensional portal where tommy
and billy are being kept but the thing
that this keeps coming back to is as
intense and scary as as intense as this
looks as uh you know scary as some of
the imagery is it just constantly feels
like it's gonna be a visual feast and
exciting and then you have christine
palmer red hair looks great she has been
right here before hasn't she i feel like
since we saw another this is what i mean
the trailers have done such a good job
on confusing me because you do see in
another trailer where christine palmer
is getting married and strange is
attending the wedding now i don't know
if that is our doctor stranger we're
watching a variant version of this i
imagine that would be our doctor strange
watching that and then this red hair
christine palmer is a different
christine palmer she is a variant
because she seems like she's all brand
new to everything that dr strange is
doing because she's familiar with with
steve and strange's sorcery abilities
but when she's watching him do his
ritual she looks completely horrified by
whatever it is that's going on there and
i don't know what that'll lead to with
their connection if they're if strange
is going to start up a romance with this
version of christine palmer
stephen strange the illuminati will see
you now
i'm excited this is gonna be a trip of a
film i i already have tickets to three
showings yeah i'm going i i can't wait
so please subscribe click that
notification bell leave a like
because this is going to be one hell of
a roller coaster thank you reject nation
for being here and keep a lookout for a
moon on episode 5 reaction episode
action
you